and winter final coming up it's gonna be
either double or Chickering though now
look we talked about doubles record
let's talk about chicken he was playing
really really strong and just barely got
into it on this winners side because of
one of the record conflicts right that
was one of the things that made sure I
made a difference into getting on that
winners side or that loser side
Chickering playing very strong looking
good so far I'm interested to see double
has been pretty spot-on all year I mean
he has not take it those big victories
like he's wanted to I feel like right
but they cease right now he's on the
cusp of it this matchup in particular
though he's actually rematch from Summer
Jam I believe if I'm not mistaken pretty
sure them in the grand finals of that
tournament Chickering took their wand
that tournament double went home with
second place so this is a run back with
double I think today double is a
different beast than you was at Summer
Jam he is on point everyone we're doing
has been working out I've been very very
impressed
look there's there's not too many
players here in this top eight that we
that even in the group play that I have
not been impressed with right before but
everybody's not gonna make it but here
we go
I mean like impressed by a relative to
themselves like double to himself right
now new level Noby to myself right now
new level of course oh definitely of
course but here we go guys if you guys
would like double to take it make some
noise ladies and gentlemen okay okay
what about Chickering if you want
Chickering to make it even further in
his tournament make some noise guys all
right all right
Japan misses Japan to run back from
Summer Jam
all right the geese shows his face the
goose is loose and why did pretty good
character in this matchup
really yeah you can parry a lot of the
second strings and ducks there so we'll
see out double-dog he has a ton of
experience matchup and I love the way he
does he just watch what - dub is a walk
of a look at chicken with the sidewalk
stand up die walk up gets two down three
on top of
[Music]
if we see our early lead if this stays
the same that it is right now Chickering
look at her like he's in charge for one
plus two break on the toilet or it came
back it was to be numbers at the same
time I went right back to 12 getting the
first round
alright round number two
game number one like I said chicken was
still looking super strong now back to
you to start off the pressure nice down
jabbing while he was at who play he
didn't burn anything too early he was
only a second or the third round when he
started doing it but look at the damage
out are they all yeah double he's
getting beat up right now he's got the
red though low potent oh yeah them mixed
up there off the dss goes with the mid
option yeah using it Castle keeping the
pressure on top of it actually gets it
to hit yeah while standing one not gonna
work out cancels into the reppuken look
at the light in the picture to enhance
Oh second round going toward in another
successful walk on the side of chicory
this is exactly what I was talking about
yeah double he's using too many linear
moves antiquities making pay right now I
use his head DSS to get a little
difference between to see is waiting is
perfect time to attack before pulling
any triggers on anything yeah you can
see sometimes even sting dunking longer
right extending that duck animation
maybe looking for low fairies and just
trying to throw up double timing down to
another one do it again for three thirty
seconds left on the clock don't we look
at a lot better this round
you have transition brakes the throw I
like throw those oh wow or two with the
trait definitely get the wall it's gonna
be close huh oh hello dad
give him another one it was like close
I'm like bro heavy do you not remember
playing with a lot of laughs every
season 3 feet long we got wall cobble
specifically Oh
go straight put the slide after the plot
low okay grab a nice tectum chicken in
here throw brakes on point how does he
do that - if it's a while spinning Wow
you tried to go for down 3-1 he's not
closing a wildlife look at the damage
because of made it completely whipped
get off the suit this is a real gold
world just like the trophy right God
that you know if he's ridiculously my
jam check they're from double I like the
switch up here right but slower approach
not giving chicken as many options to
size of them and that's I'm using the
homing attack the chickens would step
towards final round game one already
double bringing it back and there we go
again it bit me
that's gonna come a halflife lead even
more so doubling up by foot behind
you're down - can you add it up
all you finish the string double the
trouble
plaintiff or DSS cancel the back to
break the throw steel double in trouble
oh the double special yeah he liked to
throw out that back for three chicken
hat it's got it ready to get the doctor
and the punished closes out closes out
that first game Stage Select I think is
over going man double almost brought it
back right there but how do you stop
chicken
I feel like his meter utilization has
gotten even better from group plates on
now I mean even from earlier in the year
to now I watch this guy stream lot and
he goes down the list of the things he
needs to perfect to be in top form in
tournaments a you see it right here yeah
chicken definitely one of those players
has performed very well throughout the
year
you know it's he's but kind of hit or
miss sometimes you remember where you
first that went out to Pakistan it was
like oh I guess maybe chick was not that
guy you know but all said here is
witness I top eight one game away from
making it to the winner's final look
Pakistan has been the place where a lot
of top players of went this year to get
that extra power up rang it makes a lot
of sense we sing a new transform
chittering right here I mean what it's
done for me is will I mean he's always
been ridiculous but that Pakistan trip
powered them up yeah definitely a chain
of events right but here we go Game two
old to slide to but the Lightning this
time in favor of double not for long
couples to corrode number I love the
stable just right up in his face making
him commit to something holy crap double
flip man yeah I mean W looked up to the
sky after that was like what am i doing
man I gotta pull it back together his
beef is he's having such a hard time
opening chick Chickering up chicken gets
the lead and get you relaxed I know Mary
for dumping and trying to get something
started you're down two people to wall
Carrie to close okay any decent damage
on the wall right here go put it back on
that wall decent I mean a lot of damage
on the wall damn it catches up swinging
in the middle of a string nice sidewalk
Oh
either get away from there wall he needs
to get away from that wall you know ee
loves to keep that pressure going for
one plus two that's a good tool to do it
mm-hmm yeah but it's easy to cookies the
counter too so you can't see the car now
get to lick off 50 50 times get the long
double on the board here
okay all right this is a lot better foam
that way you keep that round count close
especially an early second game steal
two out of three sit you want to keep it
as close as possible and more down back
to easier he's gonna use the treatment
down back reach down for two it is a
frame trip plus one down back three home
so I walk on the reppuken magic kick
down for three don't what would it be
right now starts with the jam twenty one
after one plus two so I walk trying to
wait for something the chickens defense
not holding up the life lead in favor of
double we're almost in 25 seconds right
now double looking much we're slowing
things down and you can see he doesn't
wanna come in here he scared the Calgary
scared the sidewalk but he doesn't get
the throw break and now he's got rage
chickens got meter two and he's one of
those guys that will conserve that meter
if you have no we're going straight for
the rage aren't you're definitely big
yeah you're definitely dead
I've been hit too many times there's a
lot of these strings that chick word is
using that lock in acne parity second to
third hits up these lobbies go cook
there's a low prairie from chicken here
and that's one of the things oh we saw
nobody doing it as well he was not
letting finish those drinks he was
reversing a second I mean even you see
right and look at the flip get got a
double get the crowd cancel into the
capo here Big Bang boom nice push backs
in a bit on the stage closer to the
Waldo chicken has one ball likely still
in favor of double this get second game
looking so much better back three to
nothing
mmm-hmm delete just obviously you don't
want to just whip the parry except on
because you can get locked by another
factory too so a little bit risky but
double your you kind of visually see it
and you can see I'm teasing with a Yoho
Wow beautiful stuff from chicken they're
finally opening now it's gonna be set
point for chicken here every time just
turning the car back around he's like
we're going this way no going this way
it's not done yet don't count him out
the horse will get expensive ear
- belt look damn it double with Bukit
double try to finance counter - down
back threes that time legend kick he's
opening up the offense but look at
chickens defense this is what I exactly
what I was talking about I feel like
this is directly related to the Pakistan
train oh ok this is gonna be big damage
not gonna be a big deal but it's gonna
hurt he finished watching me play bro
come on he's been watching you huh I
mean there's only was some ways you can
pick up something so stuff alright but
it works it works doubled on the board
here double going with the 10 string to
close it out wow that was awesome
oh man I can't believe that worked
I mean you called it yes there's only so
many times only so many times geometric
plane man chicken loves the stage I
think it's a song you okay anymore [ __ ]
are you looking at your arm like oh my
god final games in the side of the
bracket how dare you
fight using it so soon but double you
know you really had to dig deep to get
that last game let's even keep the
momentum going here see double steel
trying to find this open early on be
coming from chicken early slide side
switch that's the first slide we've seen
out of them and they were really mixing
things up here
I love the poker game I love the full
game no combos just punch it's the small
pulse was using totally different moves
now right back three back to down one
almost didn't using that first game and
look at what is down for him
Yoshi's chicken right to the wall and
his favorite old my gosh cancelling that
down for into reppuken yeah but doubles
soul we're never here for four he's
gonna get to walking short oh definitely
here comes check right now damage your
Oakley he wants the damage spring kick
Wow and she was not ready for a punish
on it caught him off guard doesn't
matter though huge leap for chicken here
in round two sliding on his power to the
people while standing to right now you
know how the key tarts no get up the
goal speculated whip T that was a oh he
gets the wall to drag it
I know you know I know the win now he's
just a bad yeah Oh
break his legs not again hey freak I
want +2 it Oh counter hit trait I don't
know what's gonna happen else baby chick
are in reading the block oh [ __ ] wind is
hesitating now but his defense was
spot-on in Game one but now Adsense
progress he's starting to fall apart
here he talked about double using these
new moves to open him up maybe he loses
the field maybe he's not sure where he's
gonna go for a pig launcher here and the
combo of the tape but doesn't matter
double now on that point
- I'm Tony winners final and this is two
out of three he's gonna be meeting me if
he can close out this round set point
here Oh chicken dope back three two max
mode cancel steel has one more fall on
top of it this is definitely not out of
ESA's wheelhouse he's got plenty of
meter to send this to a final round even
potentially get to the final round by
saving the meter - just life good what
put you off Oh trying to back up and
it's what I was talking about you tell
me this is what you were talking about
children is definitely hesitating now
he's facing into the meter and we're
going to a final final round
Chickering vs. double one of these guys
gonna be said to lose McNeil was going
the winner final now double the dss it
was a low this time he's got the counter
in 94 oh-ho this is not looking good
apart for chicka right now tries to go
for the throw great dunk right there
chick who and still has a chance though
what was that an accident put mm control
you know God be careful keep that meter
this is gonna hurt a lot he's also got
rage look at the water damage oh here's
a present yet it's close is anyone
Oh God Chikara double went for such a
risky attempt there and he see him
collapsed after a chicken get in the
victory and punching his ticket to the
winner's final to go up against me
man what a showing still so far man oh
that was so close down to the wire and
that crazy combo from chick or not the
end there spent the reader didn't even
even he had the rake but enough to spend
the raid generally did not and that's
what I was talking about he was playing
earlier he was being so critical of how
he was gonna use his meter to close out
rounds even more so not using that meter
to the second or the third round in some
instances we got to this match versus
double the minute he got the hit
spending that bad boy and look how it
worked out I love the way he thinks
about and how he changes up his mind
saying going further into this I mean
maybe his character dependent maybe his
player depend it but it worked out yeah
and you know the thing I've been saying
about the tech and World Tour in general
whoever you expect to win the tournament
has not won the tournament the last
year's when kudos one no one expected
into when people thought was gonna be
st. or JD CR that year last year was
like oh it's near coud on but then it
was ranked you could it be Chickering
this time I mean no one was talking
about a chick when winning the t TT
finals but now he's in position to do
just that look we still got plenty of
more matches to play and we got our next
one waiting for you guys on my god
Ashley difference is this is losers side
and